bought fours bratwurst
curry Wurst at London's lively Soho
district Herman's a German is all the
rage like very good quality and this
flavorful I like it it's got flavor to
it I spent a year in Berlin as part of
my studies so I thought it'd be nice to
maybe see the German style cuisine was
lived up to what I'd experienced
actually in Germany I don't usually eat
curry Vorst but because I don't live
there anymore a coevals too started to
feel like a bit of home when he followed
his girlfriend of Britain ten years ago
Florian fried never would have predicted
that he'd one day turn into a sausage
seller back then aza de Falak Shah he
was still studying in Brighton I can't
say that I ever wanted to sell sausages
neither of us planned that no way it
started out really small but then took
off and now of course we're really happy
it worked out the way it did the sausage
business began because of the couple's
love of the food but to get proper
German sausages they had to import them
from their hometown butcher back in the
Black Forest first for themselves then
for friends I filled up our suitcase
isn't even our backpacks it was a lot we
missed it it's always like that when you
leave things behind you think that's so
delicious why don't we have it here and
you want to show everyone how tasty it
is and so Herman's a German was born at
first the two hip music festivals in a
converted trailer and sausage lovers
bought in droves one reason was the
business name incorporating a well known
German mispronunciation everybody he
walked by laughed and took pictures they
didn't even look at what we had to eat
just a logo on the side of the trailer
was enough to interest people fed
offseason trailer I was led to tire into
a son fiddle order that weekend we sold
almost everything we had and we had
really ordered a lot
we couldn't believe the couple opened
their first store front three years ago
in central London not far from Trafalgar
Square lunch is generally very busy the
house specialty is curry Wurst
now with two eateries Herman's the
Germans owners need around one and a
half tonnes of curry ketchup to meet
demand every month to garnish 800
kilograms of sausage imported from
southern Germany
lots of people say oh they won't be able
to tell you something cheaper but I
don't agree there's so many great places
to eat in London you have to offer the
best you can if you want to be taken
seriously and succeed that's the bar
stool it's my meeting her stuff into the
Herman's a German menu includes
sauerkraut even though it's not actually
traditional to eat sausage with
sauerkraut in Germany but then try
telling people and Britain that the
customers got quite upset about it
they'd say if there's no sauerkraut than
I don't want sausage either you mean
your German and you don't have
sauerkraut so we thought okay if that's
what they want we'll sell it and these
days we eat it too because it is pretty
tasty I would now and again London now
has a number of sausage snack bars like
the force club in the city or the courts
and long at nearby Smithfield market but
Herman's a German remains the most
popular even celebrity chef Jamie Oliver
sought tips from Floria and fry on his
popular television show
what's inside knowledge on this wagon if
you've entered Germany with this product
then open Texas in 2012 the two Germans
did the catering at the MTV Europe
Awards and immediately gained a new fan
supermodel Heidi Klum ordered a dozen of
Hermann sausages but one last question
who is Herman's a German well he's a bit
shy I think I saw him this morning
sometimes drops by you'd like him but
he's a little unusual Urban's the German
might shun the limelight but this
sausage ambassador to London has
certainly done his job well